tutti ragazzi e benvenuto e questo nuovo
video sono fare i j
oggi scouts lei primis l'aria da quant'è
che non faccio con le vacanze non mi
ricordo neanche come si gioca
praticamente va bene ragazzi ho notato
come sono entrato su happy meals questa
è la home page nella compagnia è più il
mondiale il secondo livello è fa vj art
donation fatto dal gas o ferite raga non
so come si pronuncia quindi perdonatemi
per inaugurare il ritorno su itunes
direi di fare questo come primo livello
saldo al paziente dottor fuori j non so
i guanti ma perdonatemi baba iniziamo
larger simboletto il trapianto di cuore
ok ragazzi
prepariamoci al trapianto cos'è sta roba
mi ha sparato un cuore fantastico dog
datemi la sala operatoria che opero
datemi a questo è un cuore come si deve
raga ragazzi opero cuori serio soltanto
cuori che meritano di essere salvati e
cosa sta facendo cioè non stop qual è
qual è lo scopo di sto livello cos'è è
un ma io sto toccando nulla c'è sta
facendo tutto lui va bene stiamo a
guardare tranquilli fratello di uk
ma quella è una bambina non è un maschio
vabbè non importa boltro ragazzi cos'è
stano
che l'ambulanza di so cos'è è un buddha
quando ci sono la bola cos'è dotta alfa
vj ragazze è presente che prima di
riuscire in un trapianto io faccio un po
di tentativi ecco diciamo che sono tutti
quelli a destra questo momento va bene
comunque il livello è fantastico grazie
mille ansioso 92 per cento imposti con
rega
come stai caro vecchio steve da quanto
non ci vediamo allora facciamo vedere
che nonostante le vacanze
nonostante le vacanze vi si riesce a
incastrare nei muri perfetto allora
dobbiamo riuscire a fare bene
allora ragazzi ci vuole un po di
allenamento giustamente dopo le vacanze
giusto che si riscaldi leggermente
estivo allora ci siamo
stavo passando cosa sto facendo
c'è la chiamata ovvero si potra la
salute
ho vinto ho vinto c'è una cosa da quando
si può vincere attraversando il muro
cioè non lo sapevo mi è nuova a sta cosa
va bene ragazzi io questo nuovo nuovo
tipo di impossible
da adesso in avanti stima è diventato
talmente pro che può attraversare i muri
tranquillamente ragazzi steve è un
fenomeno voi non avete idea di
superpoteri che lui a ragazzi detto el
atmosfera cos'è sta roba
non lo so mi avevate detto cose o dio
c'è un mostro oddio c'è un mostro nel
cesso pajetta nonno motorino dove torna
da me motorino perché ti sei preso lui
prendi anche me prendi anche metti su
oddio oddio no no no scherzavo scherza
musica risucchiato concesso
ragazzi se cosa mi ricorda vagamente giù
per il tubo comunque voi non lo sapete
voi non lo sapete ma nel bagno di casa
basta cetus del cesso del bagno di casa
vostra c'è tutto questo poi non lo
sapete ancora perché sto stuprando le
gambe di uk perché non lo so va bene
andiamo avanti ce li ho che calcola ok
adesso non c'è più perfetto dire dico
sofà barbera che dobbiamo tornare su
eversione questa roba
cosa che perché c'è il padre di youtube
ragazza il padre gli uk che ha un ascia
non so perché non me lo chiedete andiamo
avanti così grande
raga non sa se ci sono delle mele
perfetto vuoi un po di mele ma levati
dalle palle
veni borschberg c'è la battaglia col
boss vene ragazzi torniamo giu perché
c'è il boss dei boss delle fogne il
ragazzo nuovo programma di realtime il
boss delle fogne cos'è cos'è questa cosa
stai facendo è di non è il momento di
farla kakà nelle fogne perfetto queste
il boss non battuto più viva bene
ragazzi questo è il livello più strano
che io abbia mai fatto nella storia di
api vis
di sicuro va beh si forzi clarté club
cos'è questo va beh noi facciamolo anche
se non sappiamo che cos'è mi avesse
detto tra l'altro che cos'è welcome to
sportscar test lab che è perfetto devo
devo entrare nella macchina press z
perfetto ci siamo vai e ti puoi vedere
le tue abilità di pilota ma è così
grande
il progetto adesso andiamo avanti nel
tempo tipo ritorno al futuro
questa è la rincorsa che dobbiamo
prendere perché troppo andremo nel
futuro ci siamo ragazzi ci siamo detti
pronti mai così vai col viaggio nel la
pensavo molto più veloce è una gara vai
vincerò io bastardo sta trattando
ragazzi sta trattando perché io sto
guidando da sdraiato e lui invece seduto
non vale benissimo già dovremo fare è di
che cazzo stai facendo famme capì già
nonno ciak investirono il ciak perché
c'è ragazzotto mi avete detto ho vinto
io ho vinto io ti sei fermato prima
pietra
ho vinto io
ragazzi mi avete letto che c'è un nuovo
personaggio in happy meals che io non lo
sapevo neanche sa cos'è sta roba
mi sa che chi ha un po sbagliato che non
lo sa acrobazia riuscita è perfetto e
che precisione vero nel saltare i cerchi
bene ragazzi devo cos'è qua partono
macchine così non si sa perché va bene
vajente guida come si deve ma l'edizione
mi sono incastrato no e di no no che
etica forte chi è che ha dato la patente
non ho jacques siamo messi bene così
grande
vabbè devo provare il prossimo
personaggio di happiness quello nuovo
appena il prossimo livello se riesco lo
faccio giro nella morte per è di
grandissimo ok va bene
così va bene così noi continuiamo che
può degenerare la cosa va bene così
uccidi il melone no questo lo devo fare
assolutamente ragazzi devo tu non puoi
passare non importano noi non passò
voglio prendere solo il melone c'è il
mira e lorena chi caduto tra l'altro
cioè non so se doveva accadere ai
ragazzi io vorrei prendere d'uno ciak
più che il melone va bene prendiamo il
me non è così
ok due al prezzo di uno fantastico
ragazzi e ricordatevi che se comprate un
melone di questi tempi potrete avere un
nonno ciak in omaggio in già tre ninja
training lo devo fare ma che siano lo
volevo con e di un'edizione vabbè non
addio che volo si è fatto non c è di che
cazzo fai ragazzi già faremo ce la
faremo
cos'è sta roba è imposto il possible
l'ho passato passato anche in posti con
effetto ho vinto non ha vinto ha
dimenticato la moneta maledizione dov'è
quella foto eccola sul perfetto può
trovarla
ho scaricato anche luke quindi è finito
nel migliore dei modi al salva ibarra
che cos'è borsa ormai con non ho paura a
provarci sinceramente abbiamo
sopravviverà dei palloni da calcio
qualche difficile c'è solo luke può
essere così
monetta chiudere da un pallone da calcio
non è possibile perché dark basketball
crociani jarque
non lo so vediamo connetti ma è così vai
e vai maledizione lanci di prova
sì sì sì ho fatto che adesso con un
braccio vale lo stesso si è
evidentemente vale lo stesso no
aspettate un attimo ci riprovo grande
era che hanno trovati altri per farvi
già andando avanti nelle pagine c'è il
99 per cento impossibile poi vj dai
falli find a cosa è vita ovviamente fa
vj non andare qui ma tu mi stai
prendendo in giro nero allora noi due
abbiamo fonti sospeso ok io e te abbiamo
[ __ ] conflitto aspetto non mi poi
crollare così non ne ha il diritto
vai favi ma se mi fai leggere vai fabi
ce la farai adori più vivo sono
fantastici
grazie mille per il complimento come
puoi vedere ti sei già risposto quindi
ci siamo
direi di cambiare livello ragazzi che mi
chiedete se ce la faccia ce n'è bisogno
lo sapete che non ce n'è bisogno vabbè
mini games per pa vj sempre riferite sei
un genio te lo ripeto perchè tanto ormai
è scontato
vai così gli occhi al padre di luca
allora e dobbiamo andare su in io non
pensavo effettivamente di tirare una
palla così grossa bene va bene che per
riscaldamento se voglio lo posso fare
anche a occhi chiusi che credete c'è ma
c'è neanche bisogno che io ripeto se lo
sono tutti ragazzi lo sapete che con me
non si competa grande il padre dio caso
avevo riuscire a prendere luke c'è una
spada sola l'ho già persa non ce l'ho
porca [ __ ] non so come ho fatto a
sbagliare un'inizione cio riprovare
aspettato un secondo se ok siamo su in
sollecito a mancare uk non so a [ __ ]
allora questa è quella buona 1 e 2
cadi maledetto stronzo cadi se non so
come ho fatto ma me l'ha data buona
grandissimo ed va bene va bene così non
importa non è accaduto effettivamente
gli occhi ma non ditelo a nessuno fate
finta di niente rock swing e tutti
insieme
no no mio dio che salvataggio epico no
sono ancora io scrivo solo tra
un'edizione ce l'aveva quasi fatta mio
dio o chi era che ci siamo ci riprovo
vai così è di vaio
allora ce la possiamo fare prima siamo
morti per niente non so come abbiamo
fatto ma ce la possiamo fare è di sì no
no è di le tue mani almeno avranno la
gloria neanche quelle si lascia possiamo
fare forza mani forza mani le mani
stanno avendo un loro perché è dice
ancora vivo se fosse ancora vivo teri
allunga le braccia e prendere la corda
invece no torrey nextreme cos'è questo
mi sembra mi ispira tipo cadono le
bottiglie cos'è bottone in pochi e c'è
il di mi avevano detto che te li dato un
po all'alcol ma non pensavo così tanto
abbia non importa riproviamoci devo
sopravvivere come fare se non sopravvivo
fatto si sono vivo
no devo raggiungere la bottiglia voglio
bene la petizione
ok è di mi spiace non ce la facciamo
morirai così va beh direi di cambiare
andiamo direttamente su fa vj non ci
riesci fatto da ti stimo fa vj ti fanno
scrivere se ce la fai sclero io
allora equa amico mio dovrà sperare
soltanto una persona e quella persona
ciò delle frecce del pene maledizione ce
la posso fare
posso c'è ma che cazzo
allora e ti sembra facile questa è una
sfida una provocazione cosa stai
cercando di dimostrare amico mio non ce
la fai tanto vinco io con sé dove sono
ok è di ieri avessi non devi andare
sulla luna va bene così hai già dato
dimostrazione di saper saltare non ti
preoccupare va bene abbiamo vinto adesso
voglio vederti sclerare comunque vabbè
raga dire di concludere qui per questo
episodio prova il solito 6 viso è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video tratta nella descrizione
serie sindacalisti iscrivetevi ci
rivediamo in un prossimo vito bene
ragazzi